okay so this is my spoiler free review
of catch-22 the new miniseries on Hulu
it is produced by George Clooney he
directs the fourth episode and the final
episode and that's kind of out of
fashion usually the big director is the
first two episodes of a series so it's
kind of nice to see a change of pace
here I had no expectations for this show
I had never read the book I hear it's a
classic though and let me tell you this
was a big surprise for me how good this
was this is how you do a miniseries it's
not too long it's exactly six episodes
and every scene here has either a really
good humorous side to it because it is a
very dark satire but it also has not
just the humorous dark side of it but
also just dark and it gets heavy it's
emotional I'm not the biggest fan of
satire as a whole but this won me over
and people were worried about that just
know that there's so much deep story
here and it isn't all just jokes it's a
perfect blend and you see that George
Clooney is only in a little bit of this
he's a minor part as his Hugh Lowry
they're both great in it I wish you
Larry was used just a little more he
kind of seems pointless but George
Clooney's great as usual and what
worried me was what happens in that like
that movie Hail Caesar that is running
off of the basis of that humor I hate
which is like oh it's funny because it's
George Clooney doing this and he kind of
does that a little bit with goofy dances
and stuff but if you get past that he's
still grating it it's not all about that
and the lead in it is actually the
boyfriend from the show the sinner the
actor of Christopher Abbott who is kit
harington's long-lost brother and he is
incredible and his acting is worth alone
this watch and this is a big talent now
that is just on the scene he is on the
map this is one hell of a performance
this show I think will win awards I
think his performance will win something
and it's one of those shows
that you can binge right away I will say
however that it kind of felt like one of
those shows where episode one is great
then episode twos and then episode three
is great episode fours and it's like the
odd number episodes are way better than
the even numbers so you do feel a little
gets a little slow up parts but it all
has pay off again it's based off a very
popular novel and the way it talks about
war and opens your mind to a lot of that
is crazy there's so much deception of
war and movies and TV and this felt just
like something still I haven't seen
before and you learn so much from it and
they really just do a hell of a job it
looks really good and the directing is
top notch by Clooney and by the other
director who does a couple the episode
so it's definitely worth a watch put it
on your list I'm gonna give this show a
8 no I'm gonna give it a 9 point one
that is my gut instinct I think you'll
really enjoy it definitely check it out
and if you're not into war stuff because
this takes place during World War two
you're still gonna like this again
that's not my preference either but I
still enjoyed it so it was something
that's not really my taste that was
going against my grain and I loved it so
check it out